so we had the hundred logicians all of
their foreheads were painted blue and
before they entered the room they were
told that at least one of you at least
one of you hundred logicians has your
forehead painted blue and then every
time that they turned on the light so
that they could see each other they said
okay once you determine that you have a
blue forehead when the lights get turned
off again we want you to delete leave
the room and then once you know that's
kind of settle down they'll turn the
lights on again and people look at each
other again and then you know they'll
turn them off again and maybe people
will leave the room so far or it's so
forth and so on and they're also all
told that everyone in the room is a
perfect logician they have infallible
logic so the question was what happens
and actually maybe a even interet more
interesting questions why does it happen
so I'll answer the first what happens
and this if you just take the answer you
don't know why it almost seems mystical
is that essentially the light gets
turned on and off 100 times and then
after the hundredth time that the light
gets turned on so 100 times after the
hundredth time that the light gets
turned on and the lights get turned off
again all of them leave they all lead
they have after F so I mean it's kind of
weird right
we let's say I'm one of them or you're
one of them right I go into this room
the lights get turned on and I see 99
people with blue foreheads and you know
there's I there's i don't can't see my
own for it they see my forehead of
course but i'm one of you know to each
to any other person I'm one of the 99
right but I see 99 blue foreheads so
essentially what happens if we were to
watch this show is the lights get turned
on you see 99 blue foreheads the lights
get turned off again then light and then
lights get turned on again and then all
over one's still sitting there and I
still see 99 blue foreheads and that
happens that happens a hundred times and
after the hundredth time the lights gets
turned on everyone leaves the room and
you know at first
at a kind of first glance that seems
crazy because nothing changes right
nothing changes between every showing of
the I guess every time we turn on the
light
but the weighty need to think about this
and this is what makes it interesting is
what happens instead of 100 let's say
there was one person in the room so you
know before the show starts but sat you
know they never told me that they're
going to be a hundred people in the room
they just said at least one of you at
least one of the people in the room has
your forehead painted blue and then as
soon as you know that your forehead is
painted blue you leave the room and that
everyone's a perfect logician so imagine
the situation where said of a hundred
there's only one perfect logician let's
say it's me so that's the room I walk in
and I sit down and maybe I should do it
with the blue and then they turn the
lights on and say look at look around
the room and I look around the room and
I see nobody else right and remember
even in the case of one we've painted
everyone's forehead blue so in this case
this one dude or me or whoever you want
to call him his forehead is painted blue
so he looks around and and he sees no
one in the room but he remembers the
statements and maybe it's even written
down on a card form and in case he
forgets that at least one of you has
your forehead painted blue so if he
looks around the room he says well I'm
the only dude in the room and they told
me that at least one of the dudes in the
room it's going to have the foreheads
blue well I'm the only dude in the room
so I must have a blue forehead so as
soon as they turn the lights off he's
going to leave alright fair enough
that's almost a trivially simple and and
today you might say well so how does
this apply to 100 right well what
happens when there are two people once
again both of them have their foreheads
painted blue so let me draw another I
don't want to keep drawing the the blue
forehead room let's say there's two
people now so right when the so let's
put our hit our selves in the heads of
this guy right right behind the blue
forehead that's where we're sitting okay
so when he enters the room when you know
he says I either have
I either have a blue forehead I have an
appointment meeting let me cancel that I
either have a blue forehead or I don't
have a blue forehead no blue right this
is this is what this guy is thinking
let me draw him and he has a blue
forehead but he doesn't know it he can't
see it that's the whole point about
painting the forehead blue as opposed to
another part of the body so he says I
either have a blue forehead or I don't
have a blue for it he walks in right he
walks in let's say this is this guy he
walks in the first time the lights get
turned on he sees this other dude there
who has a blue forehead and he says okay
now let me think about it
how will this guy respond depending on
each of these states so let's say that I
don't have a blue forehead let's go into
this reality if I don't have a blue
forehead what is this guy going to see
well when the lights get turned on he's
going to see that I don't have a blue
forehead and we were both told that at
least one of us has a blue forehead so
this guy because he's a perfect logician
will deduce that he has to have a blue
forehead remember this is in a situation
if I assume that I don't have a blue
forehead we're in this world right I'm a
perfect logician so if i can assume if i
if I'm kind of a simulating the reality
where I don't have a blue forehead then
this guy will see I don't have a blue
forehead and then he'll say I must have
a blue forehead and so when the lights
get turned off this guy will leave the
legs at the room and you know vice-versa
that the other guy will make the same
logic but let's but since both of them
have blue foreheads right what happens
the lights get turned off then the
lights get turned back on when the light
gets turned back on this guy is still
sitting here right and I just determined
that if I didn't have a blue forehead
and this is me
if I didn't have a blue forehead this
guy would have left right because he
could have he could have said oh I must
be the only guy with a blue forehead so
he would have left but since he didn't
leave I now know that I have a blue for
so then the second time that the lights
get turned off or the after the second
the second time that the lights get
turned on I can deduce that I have a
blue forehead and then when the lights
get turned off again I'll leave and this
guy he's a perfect logicians so he makes
the exact same conclusion because he
also kind of simulated and said okay if
I didn't have a blue forehead this guy
would say if I don't have a blue
forehead then this guy will leave as
soon as the lights get turned off the
first time right if this guy doesn't
have a blue forehead then this guy will
say well I'm the only guy in the room
with the blue forehead well I see no one
else in the room with the blue forehead
and since I know that there's at least
one with the blue for it I'll have to
leave but since he didn't leave this guy
will also know that he must have a blue
forehead as well so they'll actually
leave together maybe they'll bump each
other
bump into each other on the way out fair
enough now what happens if you extend it
to three people so we already said if
you have one person in the room he'll
leave the first time the door he'll come
to the conclusion the first time that
the lights are turned on and then he'll
leave right when there are turned off if
you have two people it takes them
essentially two times for the light to
get turned on to reach that conclusion
now if you have three people if you have
three people and I think you see where
this is going
you have three people one two and three
and remember no one knows if their
foreheads are painted blue but the
producers of the show actually did paint
everyone's forehead blue so this so once
again let's get into this guy's head so
this guy says he's either blue or he's
not blue not blue so in the reality when
he's not blue what what's going to
happen well this guy and this gets a
little bit confusing but if you think
about it from the previous example it
makes a lot of sense right a not blue
person actually doesn't it a person who
has a not blue forehead actually
shouldn't affect the outcome of what the
blue people do because let's say that
this guy says well what's going to
happen if I'm not blue
well these get this guy is going to look
at that guy
oh he has a blue forehead he doesn't
have a blue forehead
so if I don't have a blue forehead this
guy is going to see two people without
blue foreheads right and he's going to
leave the room on day one right but then
let's say or not day one but the first
time that the lights are turned on he'll
come to the conclusion now the second
time the lights turned on this guy will
say gee this guy didn't leave the room
that guy doesn't have a blue forehead
and this guy didn't leave the room
because he must have seen someone with
the blue forehead therefore I must have
a blue forehead and so if this guy
doesn't have a blue for it both of these
guys would leave the room the second
time that the light gets turned on now
what happens if they don't leave the
room the second time that the lights are
turned on well if I was not blue they
would have left so if they haven't left
by the third showing of the light then I
know that I am blue so when you have
three people they're all perfect
logicians they all have their their
foreheads painted blue on the the the
light will be shown three times or the
the light will be turned on three times
and then when the light gets turned off
they'll all leave together they'll all
leave together
and so this logic applies for any you
could have a thousand people you could
keep extending it the fourth person will
have the exact same logic will have the
same logic if he has if he has if he's
not blue if he's not blue then these
guys are going to leave after three
showings of the light or three turnings
on of the light but they don't leave
after three turnings on of the light
then he must be blue and so they're all
going to leave together all four of them
on the firt on the fourth showing of
everyone's foreheads anyway and so you
could keep extending this all the way to
100 and 100's arbiter you could do this
a million people and then they would
just keep looking at each other a
million times and then of a millionth
showing they would all reach the
conclusion that they all have blue
foreheads and they would leave the room
and then you know if you think I mean
it's it's fairly straightforward logic
but it kind of come it leads to kind of
a very almost eerie result hopefully
that that satisfies you see in the next
video